on the hill tonight for the giants will
be anthony diesel funny diesel funny 30
years of age in his seventh year at the
big league level and then 13 starts this
year he's gone six and two with a three
zero nine era and remember four starts
ago he had a start where he gave up ten
runs in one game and he still has an era
in the low threes that's impressive
for discovany as we mentioned he has two
types of fastball four and two seamer a
curveball slider and a change-up
lifetime against this d-back team two
and two but with a 2.70 era this would
be the first time he faces the
diamondbacks in a giant uniform
that's fair down the line rojas with a
base hit to get it started and josh
digging into second
[Applause]
i'm gonna stay safe
so right away a chance for katel marte
this is how things started last night
lifted middle middle and martine drilled
it into left it's off the glove of wade
and gets to the wall
rojas had to stop for a moment hustles
around third here's the throw and it's
not in time d-backs get an early break
they take a one-nothing lead that's
going to be ruled an air on lamont
weight out there in left field he just
clanked it eduardo escobar most of the
damage done against him has been from
left-hand hitters this one is punched
down the line that's a fair ball that's
in the corner
this will get martay home it's
two-nothing diamondbacks eduardo escobar
andy lapika
eduardo stays right on that fastball
working away from him
finds grass down that left field line
they're keeping lamont way busy out
there in left field in the early going
[Applause]
[Music]
lamont wade junior going back
and
reaches high over his head to get it
right next to the wall that one carried
well
on the hill tonight for the arizona
diamondbacks will be the right-hander
merrill kelly kelly is a 32-year-old
pitcher that is in his third year at the
big league level he spent four years in
the in the kbo league the korean
baseball organization
and
he really learned a pitch over there
this is his 14th start
base hit that was a shot
over the middle
posey has had some success at merrill
kelly two men on nobody out
that is hit deep down the left field
line way back there
adios
pelosi
into the tunnel
a three-run homer for buster posey his
12th home run of the year
and the giants
jump ahead just like that
full count three and two to vossler
that is a base hit down the right for
your line
into the corner
coming around third crawford he'll score
it's a double for vassler
four to two giants
clark clifford davinski
to belt he picks it
inning over
rojas hit one sharply for the final out
of the unit four to two giants wade then
yes coming up
zach gallon back for the diamondbacks
against kevin garzman
this one will stay in the yard for
reddick that's a nice quick one two
three second for merrill kelly
but he trails it 4-2
that ball is hit hard to right field yaz
on the run leaps and makes the catch
cattell marte just hit a laser beam
and just as it looked like it was going
to sail over yaz's head up he went
and he caught it
nice they've got the overshift on here
for belt nobody at third base
and belt right center field
and
it goes through
all the way out to 415
belt to second and he's going to keep on
going here comes the relay
chief
a triple for brandon belt
3-2-1 vossler
[Music]
called strike three two strikeouts in
the beginning merrill kelly strands that
lead off triple it stays 4-2
[Music]
two down nobody on vote this time pops
it up left field lamont wade juniors got
it all lined up kind of drifting on him
but he makes the play anyway anthony
discovant he's got his first one two
three inning giants lead
steven duggar who homered into the cove
last night leads off the giants fourth
duggar hits that one well to left field
that sends peralta back quickly all the
way to the wall go on
up over the wall opposite field power
and another home run for steven duggar
with one out and nobody on lamont wade
junior
now wade hits a high drive that's deep
into left field way back there still
going and goodbye
that one is gone
another opposite field home run
here in the fourth inning this one from
lamont wave junior
so two down and here is solano
solano pulls that one into left field
base hit donovan salado yostremski
scores here comes buster posey and he
will score eight to two giants
on the ground up the middle crawford
nice little pick and he throws out
escobar that wasn't easy
[Music]
brandon crawford makes the play melber
floor stepping in
wilmer blasts one down the left field
line he's gonna watch it it is gone way
up in the bleachers
wilmer flores wow
the boys are heating up belt stands in
giants have hit four home runs tonight
posey duggar wade flores belt now makes
it five
good grief up onto that arcade and gone
his ninth of the year the giants are
pouring it on
as drooble gets it up in the air down
the left field on headed for the corner
and it's gone
as drooble cabrera that's number five
make it 13-3
he did several times
mattel chops a fastball it's off belt
diamondbacks will get some runs here
vargas is home
here comes stephen vogt they will stop
rojas at third
and it's 13-5
[Applause]
by solano into center
rojas is home martay right behind
pavon smith knocks in two more
[Music]
and this should close this one
lamont way junior
and the giants
that make it three in a row